I was having my monthly haircut with my
barber he was like yeah I want to add in
like some vintage clothing and stuff
increases LTV do you have one shop that
makes a lot of money or do you want to
have many stores and he was like I want
to have more stores I was like then
don't do that you want to keep the base
unit as simple as humanly possible
because you as the single owner can
manage multiple things and you could
squeeze one store but if you want to
have 10 do the thing that costs you no
time to do and then do it 10 times for
example this guy was still cutting hair
half his income was from him cutting
hair half his income is from all the
chairs he makes a margin on all the
chairs he runs let me just get this
straight you make half your income and
that income cost you no time he was like
yeah that's like in the other half your
income cost you all your time he's like
yeah what if you just opened a second
one and cut and got rid of all of your
haircuts lived on the less here and
opened a second one because then you
make the same money and now all of a
sudden you have double the cash flow
open a third that's the the scale model